the white house undergrowing pressure to
hold china accountable for the coven
pandemic but it doesn't look like that's
going to happen
we are not at this point going to issue
threats or ultimatums what we're going
to do is continue to rally support in
the international community
and if it turns out that china refuses
to live up to its international
obligations we will have to consider our
responses at that point
dr fauci is trying to go on offense
claiming once again
that attacks on him are attacks on
science
it is essential as a scientist
that you evolve your opinion and your
recommendations
based on the data as it evolves
and that's the reason why i say people
who then criticize me about that
are actually criticizing science i put
very little weight in the adulation
and very little weight in the craziness
of condemning me you're crazy if you
condemn him okay fair enough
but uh lawrence he reminds he's got to
read the waiting room
right no one is there to see him anymore
he's like that 1981 issue of highlights
that's still in dr siegel's office you
know it served
it served a purpose a while ago but now
it's just rotting in a corner
it's like the aaa aarp magazines those
don't count as magazines
okay can i defend voucher without
defending fouchy right of course grouchy
foundation you should go
full time part of the reason why fauci
is acting this way and we're like this
is strange right
yeah but we put him on a pedestal i mean
the media
people in public life all went to this
guy so it's kind of shocking to him that
we're reaching this point
i think the most telling thing though is
not just fouchy was the national
security adviser
saying that we're going to give them the
opportunity china has been given
opportunity
there's no more time for opportunity how
do we move it forward first of all we're
not going to get the truth when it comes
to china anymore that's not happening we
should
give up on that front what we should
care about is
the people that are in government that
had a role in this in the virology
lab that's what we got to get to the
bottom of because we don't want that to
happen again
number three we gotta have an actual
conversation about
putting some pressure on china in the
right way it's an all-or-nothing thing
yeah us skating by and acting like
we got we gotta just pull the band-aid
off and we need our allies to do that as
well
the problem is is that it's going to
cost us and no one wants to pay the cost
for it because
you make it in america there's a premium
associated you make it in another
country
there's a premium associated so that's
where the real conversation no one
really wants to have that conversation
because it's going to cost
us yet also jessica to that point uh
lebron james can have a discussion about
certain things that are happening in
america but because of this cost and
this investment
he can't have that discussion in china
which makes him look like a filthy
hypocrite jessica
why are you so pro-covet
wow i actually didn't see that twist
coming but now we're here
so a few weeks ago we were talking about
how could we actually exercise some
pressure on china
that would be effective and i money is
it right that's all that we care about i
mean we
continue to push back in the south china
sea that's something we've had going on
obviously for years
um but it's got to be money and then if
it's got to be money it's got to be
these private corporations that's still
producers so we're looking at nike we're
looking at apple
we're looking at the athletes that
represent them etc and
i think that that is probably where
we're going to end up after we get
through this latest round of the who
report
now part of the blessing and the curse
of working in coalitions which we are
with the rest of the western democratic
world
is that you can't step out of line with
what macron's cat is comfortable with
and merkel right because we want to be a
united front here against china because
it killed
all of us right it took 600 000 lives
from us
it took i don't know the exact numbers
but we lost uk lives
french german everyone and so you have
to temper your response with what your
allies are comfortable with and that's
part of participating
in modern democracies we shouldn't
participate i'm not going back
yeah that was a beautiful g7 he led
there it was
it was no you're such a globalist
jessica
makes me sick to my stomach so dirty
digging what i mean there's a fair point
i mean what can be done at this point
when everything
any evidence has been tossed away and
we're you know we're involved with the
with the lab as well so what do we do
right did american money go to
basically unleash a virus that killed
four million people around the globe
uh it is on the private corporations
it's not just the companies that make
goods in china it is
all of the global multinationals based
in the united states that view china
as kind of the the golden goose and they
will literally do
anything to curry favor with the
communist party of china other than
maybe sending them banana bread and
gift certificates to bass pro shops but
you saw like what the
nba did yeah nba um backtrack
all of hollywood does that they
constantly edit
films uh to make sure that they're okay
with the communist party
uh what who was it john cena backtracked
comments that you made about
right on taiwan just one quick thing i
think
money china plays on upon our greed
and money and it's not just the g7 that
we'll take and corpora
private corporations it really will
require dozens of
corp um countries i just want to point
really quickly
to imran khan the prime minister
of pakistan that
we did an interview with a jonathan
swann
in on axios and he literally said he
would not condemn china's treatment of
the uyghurs
and jonathan swann said but it's
genocide it's forced labor it's forced
assimilation it's sterilization and he
said
we have private conversations china has
been one of our greatest friends in
difficult times when we were struggling
economically
that tells you everything that you need
to know they somebody who complains
about islamophobia will not condem
china's pro persecution of muslims
in that country true dana um
i was just noticing that china is the
biggest troll in the world you know what
they announced yesterday
that um the wuhan institute of virology
is deserving of the nobel prize yes and
then it's basically like they're they're
just gonna like
tune it it's like why are we waiting
like having this conversation and i
think
for biden remember he said i'll give you
90 days right intel
community come back to me they've got to
be thinking about what happens on the
91st day
right because if it comes back and it is
either inconclusive or it leads you to
believe that it did start in a lab or on
you know like that it was an accident or
on purpose then you have to do something
yeah and that's the next question you
know what it is though greg real quickly
it's time
the attention span of the american
public the conversation has shifted to
reopening right right and so we forget
about what took place what got us here
exactly exactly and china was protected
for months
with the media the entertainment
industry labeling any criticism
of china to be racist dan rather went
after jon stewart this weekend and he
was basically saying
you are attacking the very ideal of
science to
jon stewart and rather why is he still
around
go away hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else